the outer worlds obsidians newest
project puts the player the unknown
variable in a place and setting called
the halcyon colony this county gives the
player many places to go and people to
meet
so what if we said [ __ ] all that and see
what happens if we kill everyone as soon
as we saw them the rules for this are
simple kill everybody you see pretty
easy out of all the options I could have
picked for a video it's not the best
choice but it's spacers choice so for
the build I chose very high strength
below average dexterity high
intelligence average perception below
average charm and very high temperament
I wanted to basically be a tank and have
loads of health regeneration seeing as
I'd be a one-man army throughout the
whole run I ended up putting two points
into melee and tech since I always found
that melee to be very powerful mid to
late game and outerworld so I was trying
to prep for that this would end up being
a terrible and kind of excellent choice
later in the game as you will eventually
see the aptitude doesn't really matter
but I ended up choosing a sous chef one
because of the melee bonus and I thought
having a serial-killer sous chef was
kind of intriguing and my attempts at
making a character were very piss-poor
so I settled on the randomizer and came
across this beautiful thing I couldn't
really come up with a name but I had to
come up with something that was the
deadliest thing of all the thing that
had consumed the lives of many people on
earth so unstoppable that scientists of
this day still couldn't find a cure
jomama now that Joe has landed he had
claimed his first victim Alexander
Hawthorn the poor sap got crushed by the
ship's pod but continuing along we began
to meet our first NPC guard Pell him he
was a nice lad giving me the first
weapon of the game the spacers toys
pistol but his attitude bothered me so I
shot him a few Marauders later and we
arrived to two more spacer soldiers
lieutenant Mercer and private Kimball
who were promptly shot on sight
apparently according to the game
lieutenant Mercer was experiencing a
searing gas pain I'm glad we got rid of
that problem
finally after leveling up I picked up my
first perk and opted for more help
thinking I could do real well and this
would be a breeze I didn't put thought
into the skills this would once again
bite me in the ass later one of the many
switch ups of the game is now when
exiting the ship after going in and
talking to Ada instead of lieutenant
Mercer questioning you it is now so
dude from HR called earnest he was also
of course shot on sight
a few more dead Marauders and the
searing thirst for blood later and we
arrived at Edgewater one of the many
towns we will slaughter for personal
gain Silas does grave work duty so he
should feel right at home now and a
couple guards were around him so we took
care of them no problem and entering
Edgewater our kill count is currently at
21 the first task of Edgewater was to
gun down everyone in the town so I
started at the sick facility and put
them out of their misery after that I
went to anybody that was nearby this
became the first issue I had realized I
might miss a bunch of quests thanks to
some characters being dead
for example captain Reyes gives three
bounties as quests and without the quest
the bounties do not spawn thus meaning I
didn't kill them technically they don't
exist
so they do count as dead but I'm also
missing them and not getting the xp for
the quest or the killing one particular
man was sent to the sky after a shot to
the body this terrified me what type of
interstellar being had I just stumbled
upon what answers could he have formed
about my future whatever it was he's
dead now so it doesn't matter after the
town was slaughtered it came to my least
favorite part the rule was everyone and
that meant everyone and that also
included Parvati arguably probably the
best companion throughout the entire
game yes Vic our max was here too and he
suffered the same fate
but I liked providing more so much
showed that I wasn't even sure if I
could continue knowing my mission
wouldn't be complete without her death I
did the only thing I could that's a good
brief pause and gave her a three volleys
salute so I could resume the killing in
her honor to keep you up-to-date as well
we are sitting at currently 64 confirmed
kills which if you don't know is one
more than 63 the second realization had
came to me and thanks to me doing these
other objectives differently and not
talking to people I won't be getting as
much XP which means less skills perks
and level ups this is where I realized
this was going to be a lot harder than I
had originally thought I was going to
continue to the power plant but then I
stopped by Adelaide to see how this part
of the game played out I made it to the
Botanical Garden and found Grace who
once again was shot on sight and I
picked up her unique sniper this was
definitely my go-to weapon throughout
most of the game I also found a man so
stunned that he was in the floor with
the upper-body out I ended his life
hoping he had found peace knowing he
would not be stuck to the confines of
his bed any longer
eventually Thomas had found me in same
with Adelaide they of course met the
same fate a well-placed round into the
forehead finally going to the lab robots
interrupted me who met their mechanical
deaths but I heard a distant voice
calling out to me his name was Higgins
he was definitely on some psychedelics
assistance I was his trip sitter now I
told him everything was going to be all
right and put two shells into his back I
hope he had a good trip
and says everybody was dead I could
direct the power anywhere and nobody
would be mad at me since I hate
confrontation this actual option was
pretty relieving now that the main areas
were completed it was time to go grab
the power regulator and go to the lesser
used areas within the map to up my k/d
so I made my way to the community center
to welcome the people of my presence I
intended to select the first enemy but I
fat-fingered the mouse click and
completely missed since I wanted to be
feared by the masses knowing that I
could kill them in any split-second and
missing that shout and make me look weak
I whipped out my hammer and bludgeon
them all to death to show them that I
was the Alpha in this world on my way to
the very last area I found zou who was
also part of a side quest she wouldn't
stop talking so I put a shotgun shell in
her head hoping it would stop it worked
Miller was our last survivor and he met
the same fate as his colleagues coming
back on board with the regulator in hand
we installed it to leave her
groundbreaker
with a hundred and twenty nine kills
with five levels in and 200 bits to our
name we fly to groundbreaker to continue
our spree the ground breakers area
overall wasn't too difficult most of the
people here were civilians who wouldn't
fight back so we were good for most of
the place I couldn't get into the door
so I had to smack the wall to get his
attention to where I promptly met the
nice barrel of a shotgun to my cranium
some might call this Karma I call it
[ __ ] knowing a bit more now later I
took out Felix first since he had a
giant gun and I also failed the mission
to speak to gladdie
so the only option was to speak to Odum
until he got roasted as well so the only
alternative was to return to Ada where
she would fly me to the unrestricted
area of Monarch that was infested with
creatures upon landing but not before we
cleared out the rest of the area Ellie
wanted a fight and she also wanted to
get her friend back so I helped her by
killing her
currently that makes five out of six
companions
since technically not starting up Sam
makes him dead and if we did start him
up he couldn't die unless we were on
supernova difficulty and currently we're
playing this on normal funny enough
GLaDOS mission can actually fail before
even finding her if you have a bad
reputation with the ground breaker she
will stop her side immediately on top of
that the people have lost hope I'd also
lost more than just their hope I was
clearing out sublight when I got
distracted by a few civilians it was
definitely a setup because right behind
me after I was chasing the civilians Jun
lay and eden uh came full force Jun they
thought it'd be cool to use a melee
weapon when I had a gun so she lost her
life really quickly and Edna had the
better idea and using a ranged weapon
but had the accuracy of a child and
still lost finally back on track we went
to the very last leader of the ground
breaker ship which was sublight this was
pitiful to say the least not a single
one of them would charge me and I had
the advantage of the entire time
sticking behind the door they should
really stick to salvaging and not
shooting the last area I had yet to go
to was the underground area that you
hear during June June last quest let me
spare you the details you already know
what happened one thing that was weird
though was that the NPC's would respawn
and not be hostile to me even if I had
just slaughtered their people in front
of them even after being really sure
that everybody died in the area the game
would still respawn more settlers but it
was only the settlers none of the name
people so it really didn't bother me too
much the problem now was that my ship
wasn't pounded so I had to run over to
autumns terminal which freaked me out
cuz I don't remember which pile of ash
he was thankfully I found him and I was
on my way out of here
leaving groundbreaker with an
astonishing 250 3 kills way more than
most serial killers in history monarch a
creature infested planet with loads of
people to add to my count this is where
stuff would take a turn for the worst
raps were plentiful so they all of
course ceased to exist some of them were
tough especially the Manta Queens later
where it hit me that this would
definitely be a tougher run noticing I
was only level 7 hope just like my
ex-girlfriend was starting to leave me
but I pushed on knowing that there had
to be work to be done
cleansing this planet was a one-man job
and I was the man for that job I made it
to stellar bay home in EOKA the msi and
tons of other people waiting to be on my
kill list the first thing I heard was a
man
call out help someone has been killed
boy was he in for a treat I was in a
pretty bad spot when I entered so I
decided to go back into the beginning
where you normally would land if you
were to go through the main quest and I
shot everybody starting with grim rumata
and my signature I declined of course
and proceeded to well you know what
happened at this point stellar bay was
actually a foreshadow of the difficulty
that I had not known at the time loads
of times I actually had died here thanks
to many of the weapons that they had
were very deadly these guards took a lot
of hits and their weapons did a lot of
damage one point I had cleared almost
everybody including settlers and guards
than happened to randomly die from one
of the few guards left and since you
couldn't save all in combat I had to
restart the entire town all over again I
ended up wasting Sanjar and his
secretary friend Cecilia which was also
very sad meaning the MS I was without a
Lear with most of the guards gone I
ended up destroying Neoga who ended up
fighting me very quickly into the big
brawl that we had in town
meaning officially now that all the
followers were dead and all that was
left was the settlers and named
individuals which was a clean sweep chef
Raymond got what came to him I checked
on the TTD effects and it said that he
had nightmares recently about being
killed by a space captain well those
nightmares came true one town gone in
many more places to go Cascadia
Fallbrook CMP productions and amber
heights followed with many other smaller
places left on our list
I finally made it to amber heist on the
iron clasp the last big area of Monarch
and this was definitely one of the
toughest places in the game loads of
heavy armored enemies with machine guns
in an enclosed space was not in my cards
not the greatest circumstances that I
wanted to be in but I had to deal with
it I died countless times I was
beginning to lose more of that hope we
talked about even tried using their
workbench to load up an upgrade weapons
but being at level 8 I couldn't really
upgrade too far and even I even tried
killing grim so I could progress through
the story in hopes that I could get a
better weapon later comeback but that
failed as well so also like my
ex-girlfriend we're gonna cheat a little
bit the rules did say to kill on sight
but these guys are gonna have to wait
they will get their death soon enough
just not now so running away like a teen
ran from his parents when their jewel
gets taken a
way I headed out in search of new
weapons a new plan and more people to
add to the list and that list started
with Fallbrook full of sub like guards
that they shot me on sight since I had
already killed their leader back on
ground breaker the sublight thugs and
soldiers weren't tough the lasers didn't
hurt too much but they did hurt a little
bit so of course I had to fall back a
bit so the sniper definitely came in
handy for most of this encounter one by
one the soldiers and settlers all died
Fallbrook was one of my favorite places
and it was sad to light up everybody in
town it's got this weird indoor kind of
feeling gives me buried vibes from bo2
which is definitely a favorite of mine
so I felt real at home for killing
Fallbrook I felt better but not entirely
confident but it was a start an idea had
sprouted what if I could kill the radio
guy at doubles summit and then maybe I
could bypass the quest and get more gear
and come back later since I knew that
eventually you would have to fight the
iron class and either convince them to
do a bunch of quests for you or whatever
it happened to be or kill them on sight
and obviously we're going to kill them
and as we learned a couple minutes ago
that was very tough to do so I sprinted
to devil summit destroying everyone on
my path or my trusty hammer with my head
held high only to find out that I was
wrong I'd killed her Reem of course
immediately and checked his broker's
terminal only to discover I had to shut
down the broadcast still and thanks to
one of the guards I had an idea his
useless ass dropped a flamethrower which
would be perfect to take out grim so I
ran back full speed and kinda did it I
killed grim but the other colonists were
still killing me eventually one of my
attempts proved successful and I barely
had escaped with my life I was happy I
could progress in the game but not
entirely satisfied this Massacre would
have to wait one more day after shutting
down the broadcast and watching a ship
crash I was on my way to meet Phineas
for the very first time Phineas had
greeted me telling me here on Blyth had
passed I wonder how that happened
according to Phineas his death was
tragic but I found the death of his pet
pig bubbles to be a lot more tragic
scarred for life of what I had done I
decided to take his home as a momento
and carry bubbles with me for the
remainder of the game on the plus side
Phineas gave me the key to Byzantium but
I had actually forgot about the distress
signal two rows away another area that
we have yet to discover so we made a pit
stop at Rose way before we're going to
be
an tiem with a total of 470 kills under
our belt following the distress call we
ended up at a town with auntie Cleo
guards I met Burke a pretty nice guy but
rules are rules
so I shot him during the killing I must
have been hallucinating because I saw
two chickens in the distance bringing
him back to the old days that call of
duty I lined it up for his suite
collateral I apparently missed so before
anybody noticed I finished the last one
off for the first kill cam I had seen in
a very long time and it was glorious
Rose Way was the easier place of all of
these so far with very little guards and
the guards that were there died in
seconds rules 'we had three doctors that
needed assistance for quest because of
that distress call orson vaughn and
crane as you can expect all three of
them had passed away and della the owner
of the bar in rose way also met the
exact same fate and they all joined my
stat tracker even though I couldn't do
the question for the doctors that
doesn't mean I still couldn't go to
their respective locations and I did and
I slaughtered everyone in my path
eventually when I went to leave I must
have started seeing more hallucinations
because I swear it looked like there was
the ability to talk to chickens I tried
forever to get the words out but I
couldn't why would they not talk to me
was something wrong did they see me kill
their older brethren I didn't know at
the time but I didn't want anybody
discovering this secret for themselves
so I did what had to be done and killed
them before they told any of their
brethren to come attack me it was time
to explore Byzantium Phineas contact had
to go thankfully you can continue
without talking to her by picking up her
info on her corpse and apparently the
board doesn't seem to care that you just
straight up murdered somebody in their
basement but after killing a few
soldiers I began to see a load of people
in this corner and knew it had to be
done now personally I'm not a fan of
cooked human flesh but I feel like the
ashes could be used for some good if
anybody were to find them at this point
the board was angry with me
can't really see why but regardless of
their reasoning it was about to get a
whole lot worse Byzantium was
interesting because it was a small place
compared to the other planets but I had
lots of people in a condensed area since
it was all civilized the other Vater
music was very charming and cool to
listen to and a break from all the
fighting
until I forgot to grab the info off the
informants body and had to go ride it
back up and down again
I said mail it would come in handy mid
to late game and I wasn't technically
wrong using Grace's sniper from afar and
then hitting them with my shock baton at
a close range was the strategy Winston
for sites owner of the local gun store
was angry at me and he wandered duel but
I wanted to meet make sure it was
memorable and not some typical duel I
attempted a 360 trickshot
it went miserably but Winston was dead
so it's not like anybody could complain
about it this will have to be worked on
for future encounters like a Girl Scout
I went door-to-door murdering everybody
in my path until I got to minister Clark
the h8c building a K were the last
leader Sophia was was up next and
obtaining that after obtaining that at
[ __ ] Christ
the h8c building aka where the last
leader Sophia is was up next and after
obtaining that info that I needed to get
into the Chairman's computer killing
Sophia had me intrigued because without
her who captures her or gets captured by
Phineas at the end of the game I made it
to the Chairman's quarters grabbed the
stuff off his terminal only to find out
that Sophia had locked the door it was
completely sealed with no other way to
enter I even tried resetting all the way
back to Rose way before I even entered
Byzantium so that the board wasn't mad
at me but I still failed I gave up my
grenade launcher to a guard who would
let me into the building but I couldn't
get past the gate because I had no
clearance I tried every other option and
this wouldn't work I decided to press on
to see if something would change later
so I went into the lab to grab B
dimethyl sulfur oxide whatever the [ __ ]
it's called I'm not a scientist so I
don't really need to know that and you
can already understand what's happening
guy walk in go shoot shoot people go die
die game over when I grabbed the
chemicals I made sure to transfer all
100% of it since that would kill
everybody in the tubes bus leading to a
bigger count I cleaned up the rest of
the lab took the elevator and went back
upstairs and out the door I returned to
Phineas with chemical name I can't
pronounce in hand and was about to
return until Sofia message me even
though I just slaughtered her army in
front of her she wanted to become
partners I took up the inquest with the
intent on killing her once I could talk
to her in person the mission was to bug
Phineas computer which I did with ease
then I came back to her office expecting
another fight but none of
guards attacked me so I checked my
reputation apparently when you do one
question for her you can completely get
rid of all negative effects of the board
and I went from a hundred back to zero
just from doing this quest but it went
back up to a hundred since I had
literally slapped the leader of the
board with a shock baton then ran back
to the ship and continued on with my
quest
I told Phineas we should travel to the
hope to save the colonists he agreed and
after some careful arrangements of
people's arteries we were on the way
there
satisfied it was now time to go back to
the monarch and finish what we started
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with the iron class defeated everyone in
monarch including Cascadia and CMP were
dead monarch was a human free planet and
we ended with 752 kills we are really
reaching some large ass numbers here I
decided to stop by all the places just
to make sure everybody was dead
including the leaders and was practicing
for a little bit there was of course
people on the way there civilians
outside the bases Marauders etc so but
regardless they all died and I had a
nice time double-checking just to make
sure finally we get to the very end of
the game and we land on Tartarus I was
grounded by a soldier and was about to
kill me usually I would just run right
through this with the ID but since we
can't talk our way out of this and we
have to kill people I walked out killed
him and everyone else on this planet
using my trusty wacky stick in the
beautiful assault rifle ultra which I
had picked up a few minutes before the
iron clasp had died I ran into an issue
with one of the more tougher enemies
within this area killing me so I ended
up going up the elevator once going back
down killing a guy going back up going
back down and it was a constant strat
like this until I have cleared most of
the people throughout the floor and then
continued to wipe the rest of them later
once we cleared all three floors which
you usually would just ID through so
that you won't be caught we made it to
the control room
surprisingly it was chairman Rockwell
who had actually captured Phineas and
not Sofia since the only thing she's
capturing is well actually I don't
really think she's doing anything to be
honest the rest of the fight is what you
expect from a normal playthrough you
fight the RAM bot with the combat drones
the fight was really easy if you know
what to do just run in circles with a
shock baton and honestly this fight is a
pretty much a pushover once the fight
was over I grabbed the key and was on to
one more specimen chairman Rockwell had
mentioned that I had practiced and I did
I was opting for a sniper but realized
the baton would be more embarrassing
open the door
jumped over the table and finally landed
that 360 trickshot ecstatic that it
worked I dragged my nuts across his face
and talking so much [ __ ] like it was a
12 year old in a halo lobby
I took Chairman's keys and free Phineas
and beat outer worlds by killing
everyone and for those of you who are
wondering what the kill count was we
amassed a total of 1000 and
sixty-five kills which is really scary
to think about
overall the story for the playthrough is
pretty damn nice I had beaten this game
a couple times previously so I was
really interested to see how this stuff
would switch up it kind of sucks that
most of it was kind of a cop-out and
they basically just said check the
person's dead body or check their
private terminal but I'm glad that they
at least added any way unlike fall and
Skyrim where they had essential NPCs and
you couldn't actually do this to begin
with and before any of you asked the
reason why we haven't mentioned Scylla
throughout the video the only other
planet that I haven't talked about was
because the only area that you can
really visit is the one area that they
give you and that has a bunch of
mechanical robots the other option is
actually a base somewhere else on Scylla
but that is through Felix's side quest
that you have to go but since we killed
Felix right in the beginning we never
did get that side quest if there is
another way to get there let me know in
the comments below but to my knowledge
you definitely cannot go there but if
you somehow can that's on me then and
that's my fault
other than that let me know how you guys
enjoyed this video also let me know if
you want to do some type of first person
or third person perspective maybe
instead of me commenting on my
experience maybe I can have it be like
the narrator at the ending of the game
where you can't where he talks about the
player from his perspective from how the
events had unfolded and he just kind of
narrates over them I would totally love
to do that but let me know in the
comments below cuz I haven't seen too
many people on YouTube do that so yeah
as always let me know in the comments
below like to me if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and take care
guys seven Grace turday peace out and
enjoy
[Music]